Sherina I'm gonna get right to I may be
there this segments about the rookie or
most look looking forward to seeing this
gym for me that there's no question it's
calamari I'm fascinated by what he may
be able to do can he run circles around
NFL players the way he ran around
college players and also I have a sense
of fear almost like a parent being
afraid of his son playing football
because I worry that he says so little I
mean I don't mean that as an insult I
just worry about him because he's gonna
have some big nasty dudes chasing him
around and he is not very big yeah I'm
not sure our segments shouldn't be
called rookies you're looking forward to
other than Kotter Murray because he's
obviously we want to see what this guy
can do in the NFL because he did it in
high school I saw him play in high
school he did in college obviously I saw
him up close today nm is his freshman
year and then what he did it Oklahoma
now he struggled a little bit as a
freshman at A&M and and so there's gonna
be struggles his rookie year too and
he's got to be able to overcome those
struggles that he's going to have it
points this season but by all accounts
this kid has looked terrific at practice
so I think we're really excited
everyone's really excited Cardinals fan
or not to see how this guy does in the
preseason and see even though the
preseason isn't isn't anywhere close to
the intensity and the game planning and
the preparation and and the the first
quarter through fourth quarter changes
and and an adjustments and still you'll
find out pretty quickly whether or not
the basic physical skills translate to
that level I mentioned this earlier in
the week Chris Johnson when he was a
rookie with the Titans in 2008 they gave
him the balls I can be shot out of a can
and nobody had a shot at getting him
that translates to the regular season if
we see caller Murray moving in relation
to the defensive players like he did in
Oklahoma that's gonna be bad news for
everyone I want to see that arm on the
run I want to see that arm in the pocket
I want to see can he see over the guys
in front of him players like Russell
Wilson Drew Brees and Baker Mayfield
have pulled that off but it's a
fascination in many respects and there's
also a fear factor there because I just
worry that that he's not going to be
able to deal with those very large very
fast very
strong men who are gonna be chasing
around and hitting him like he's never
been hit before how about a couple of
others and you know Quintin Williams of
the Jets from a defensive perspective I
just love the guy he's got a great
personality but you know I think he also
is gonna be able to flip the switch and
that Smile is gonna be gone and he's
gonna be ready to to do what needs to be
done when it's time for him to create
havoc and and I feel like at some point
the 49ers yeah they just need to not pay
attention to Jets games because I think
they should have considered Quintin
Williams over Nick Bosa with that second
pick and and I have a weird feeling that
Quintin Williams is gonna have more of
an impact Shireen
well Nick Bose is on my list of guys I
want to see and it's for that reason of
course he's a guy who missed most the
last season and you know had the
productive career for what he played at
Ohio State but he didn't play that much
so I'm really excited to see Nick Bosa
with the 49ers you're right about Queen
and Williams it'll be fun to see what he
can do obviously with the Jets and then
another defensive player I think is
Devin Bush with the with the bucket
Devin white with the Buccaneers I think
he's going to be really good with the
Bucs at that linebacker position and I
think it's going to be he's going to add
a lot to that defense going forward but
I remember back a few years ago three
years ago Zico Elliot laid a hit in the
preseason oncam Chancellor just
absolutely ran over him and you knew
Zico Elliot was going to be a good
football player
that's what you want to see in the
preseason from these guys then you know
that they're ready they can play in the
NFL in week one and that's what you're
referring to with caller Murray that's
what the Cardinals want to see in the
49ers want to see from Bosa and these
other rookies they want to see plays
like that they know they're ready week
one yeah there's a basic eyeball test
and it's irrelevant to any of the
realities of being in a regular season
game but it is very relevant to the
reality of being on a football field
with other NFL caliber talent do you
pass that eyeball test and we'll be
seeing that with calimary
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports